بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين والصلاه والسلام على المبعوث
رحمه للعالمين وعلى اله وصحبه اجمعين اما
بعد فهذه رساله اوجهها الى اهلنا في
السودان وصيهم بما اوصى الله به عباده
الصالحين استعينوا بالله
واصبروا ان الارض لله يورثها من يشاء من
عباده العاقبه للمتقين اصبروا وصابروا
ورابطوا واعلموا اخواني واخواتي انه ما
نزل بلاء الا بذنب ولا ارتفع الا بتوبه
فوص ونفسي بان نجدد لله عز وجل توبه وان
نرجع اليه رجوعا صادقا فان ربنا جل جلاله
قد قال في كتابه الكريم ان الله لا يغير
ما بق قوم حتى يغيروا ما بانفسهم وقال جل
من قائل ذلك بان الله لم يكن مغيرا نعمه
انعمها على قوم حتى يغيروا ما بانفسهم
فلنغير ما بانفسنا ونجدد لله عز وجل توبه
ولنرجع اليه فانه سبحانه قادر على ان
يبدلنا بعد الخوف امنا وبعد الذل عزه وبعد
الفرقه والاختلاف وحده
واعتصامات اليه ردا جميلا وان يغير حالنا
الى احسن حال والسلام
عليكم